[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
season's greetings
here at just the facts with jay jonah
jameson we're feeling festive
and in the spirit of giving we've
invited a
rival podcaster to offer an opposing
view
on the deceptively named friendly
neighborhood spider-man app
which lets you message that mass menace
directly that's spider-man's gift to us
was the store out of live piranha but
our show presents both sides mine
and the wrong one so speak okay
well i think that app is an awesome
resource for new yorkers
this is danica hart by the way host of
the danacast
look the app just lets spidey help
people more effectively
or hack their phone paranoid much
spidey's been helping folks all over
harlem like teo at the corner bodega
and his cat sure it's all hearts and
flowers
until spider-man ruins the cat's credit
uh you know what i mean
harlem's in a renaissance since simon
krieger
built roxanne plaza they're offering
great jobs developing their clean energy
source
new form and spider-man sees a juicy
neighborhood with fat full wallets to
prey on
wait you think spider-man's hacking your
phone but you're totally cool with new
form
roxon won't even tell us how it works
because competitors would steal it
oh so that's why roxanne's security
guards need those crazy sci-fi weapons
you hate spider-man cause he's a
vigilante but you're just fine with
corporate shock troops ah
that's self-defense roxanne's under
constant attack
by that malicious criminal ring the
underground
finally we agree the underground worries
me too especially since the tinkerer
took over
the tinkerer an innocuous sounding name
for a cyber capone spider-man inspires
these lunatics
even ones we thought were gone are
coming back like the prowler
who come to think of it wears a mask and
climbs walls just like
okay man do you need like some more milk
or a nap or something
no i eat sleep and drink the truth
okay mr jameson it's the season of
giving
when we show kindness to everyone so in
that spirit
i got you a gift a gift well
you sent me the spiderman app
are you insane what if he stalks me
clearly he's a deranged friendless loner
you can always just delete it
you know how right of course i do just
tap
swipe swipe tap jared help me
spiderman's everywhere
everywhere everywhere
playstation